Speaker 1: Let's go next. Why don't we go to Peter
from Allentown? Peter from Allentown. Welcome to
the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2:
I've just kind of a quick question.
Yes. Do you think the United States
will ever totally adopt the metric system?
Speaker 1: You know, the best reason I read
about why the U.S. will not adopt the metric
system is a combination of having to reeducate
everyone and the cost of all the science, having
to make all new signs that it would just that
that it's sort of like it's a path dependent
monopoly sort of situation that we're on,
where we're so far in that it's always like, well,
it really doesn't make sense to do it. And then
you're further in and then you can say, Well, now
it really doesn't make sense to do it. So now I
don't know. I would love for the U.S. to adopt the
metric system. I really don't see it happening.
Speaker 2: I mean, there was a push I remember
back when I was in elementary school in the
seventies, there was this big push. They had
little, little cartoon, little songs like
Schoolhouse Rock, but with the metric system.
Yeah. And there was a real growth, you know,
honest push. But I just there's some I don't know
what it is about the American psyche or culture
that there's such a resistance with. Do they think
it's kind of like, you know, like 50 European.
Speaker 1: Those sissy Europeans with everything
based on tens. Obviously, we're going to have,
you know, a 5280 foot mile and a 12 inch foot.
Yeah. I mean, it is crazy. No, I agree. I think
there is that is a factor. Yeah. Though since
Europeans with their metric system, of course,
it's like almost the entire planet.
Speaker 2: All right. Well,
thanks, David. That's all I.
Speaker 1: Want to say. All right,
Peter from Allentown, thank you
very much. Appreciate the call.